what was that Lord is the queen be
Regina George don't look her in the
eye you could be really hot if you
changed like everything Hello friends I
was going to say losers but I feel like
that was probably too harsh but get in
because you're watching the big ticket
interview for the new Mean Girls movie
which is not a remake of the 2004
original film and also not a straight
adaptation of the Broadway musical but
rather a hybrid of both which I think is
so cool this movie came out in 2004 I
was a freshman in high school had just
moved to a new town and went to a new
high school so like I lived Mean Girls
And I walked out of the theater thinking
no movie had ever captured the
complicated Nuance of female friendships
and was funny in the way you made it
Tina so I can confidently say that any
movie that has come out since then has
never taken me and girls's Place aimed
at our demographic like this film is
Bible which would make you God Tina
because you wrote the screenplay and you
did it all by yourself like it's insane
we shouldn't even call it a screenplay
we should call it a language because
Mean Girls is one of the most quoted
films of Our Generation like I still
yell you go Glen CoCo to my Amazon
delivery guy so I wanted to start this
off by asking all of you what is your
favorite line from the original what
does it mean to you it could be for your
character or personally um and I'd love
to start off with jaquel and maybe we'll
make our way down oh okay well I think
for
me it's my new favorite line um it's
when Katie's like it's just plastic
because I don't I don't know I feel like
they take a lot of things seriously in
the movie we take a lot of things
seriously and it's like but none of this
is real like none of this is like it's
high school you'll get over it you'll
get through it people are mean but I
mean it's life you know but um I just
love I don't know it's just something
about it's just plastic like I don't
know it means a lot now especially doing
this movie and working with these people
you know like a lot of things that we
think matter really don't you know
things like we prioritize we don't have
to just be nice you know and uh yeah
that's my new
face um you go Glen CoCo 100% so hot
that's my faite um my favorite is we
should all just totally stab Caesar from
that speech and I love it so much
because when I was a kid I was like
who's Caesar who's Brutus what is this
about and then growing up and sort of
realizing the historical context and how
it sort of feeds into it it was just so
fun the parallel of ancient history and
High School drama I just loved I loved
that bringing together um I I think I
will also say youo Glen Coco because
it's just my brother's friend name and
like I feel like my brother's I was like
when you was writing the movie the first
time I was just like using random names
and it's just like my brother's friend
and now i' I've ruined his
life he's really nice about it but he's
just like a he's like a you know a dad
living here in Los Angeles and like yeah
that's that's me wait does anyone know
that I feel like I think so I mean I
think so yeah so funny thanks again
Glenn sometimes I'll be in Target and
I'll be like oh there's shirts with
Glenn's name oh sorry
Glenn no royalties there he doesn't get
any no we don't no we don't get
him moving on Renee uh my favorite my
favorite line is boo
you it's just amazing it's amazing also
it's just like it's so it's so like um
but like so like Blas and is just like
delivered like in this like nonchalant
like I don't know it's it's like it's an
absurd thing to say out loud to someone
else and also she's so sexy while doing
it that it's like oh wait I think like
did that just like turn me on in a
way for sure um that's why it's my
favorite it's an onion it has
layers my favorite line is
um I had it and then it was gone
listening to you say that's hot
um oh so you agree you think you're hot
cuz I think that sets up the entire film
right for sure you know the character is
just kind of digging for gold and and I
I think it just sets us up for the rest
of the film yeah well a friend of M who
actually worked with us on this he he's
been saying irregardless
now like irregardless irregardless it's
just like the rules of feminism I love I
love that one it is really makes me
giggle yeah well now it's you go Glen
CoCo that's so funny I that's just like
a great story behind it it has to be
that's so funny yeah it's so good and
all these things made us feel so scene
like still when my friend like wants to
cancel on me she's like I'm sick oh of
these things made us feel seeing the
first point of view narration that was
so prevalent at the time like in Sex in
the City that Katie gives us the
three-way calling the burn book these
were all things we lived through but
that was obviously 20 years ago so in
what ways is this movie updated Tina and
did you change the way that you played
MIss norbury at all no I don't have
enough
range that's the biggest joke of the
century Tim and I were in sort of like
kind of a weird Multiverse thing where
we're like we are the same characters
and this these people have the same
names but I tried to treat it like well
teachers see the same patterns over and
over and over in their in their decades
as teachers so like this weird reality
of like they're not the same people but
um yeah I mean I I I tried to update it
but I also always try I don't try to
chase like slang or anything that people
are saying now because by the time it
takes a long time to make a movie and
it'll be over by the time the movie
comes out so we just try to have people
talk like people and yeah but then is
there are we going to have burnbook or
is it more social media focused yeah I
mean I think you're going to get a
little bit of both like for me a
physical the physical burn book always
had this kind of evil power and I didn't
want it I didn't want it to just be like
it's an Instagram account it's like a
seen that like this idea that there was
this physical thing that then you know
explodes because of social yeah I love
that you brought up principal Duval
because I love Tim Meadows does he still
have carpo tunnel in this because I know
that
he he injured his hand before filming
the first one which is why is yeah in
the original movie he just like broke
his finger and like the uncoolest way
like he was riding a motorcycle out of
his driveway and he clipped he clipped
his mailbox it was like like sorry I'm
we're like no problem so we just I just
made him have it again for hereditary
it's so fun still battling it I love the
energy between Miss norbury and
principal Duval on screen but off screen
I love the energy between you and your
husband Jeff because I mean what an
iconic
pairing love je music for the stage play
this movie yeah the stage play uh yeah I
which Renee was in and then and then
adapting all this music like the music
team on this movie is incredible Renee
co-wrote some new songs and wrote some
songs for the for the for the new movie
um yeah and it's been thrilling to see
um him get to like continue to transform
all this music can you tell us a little
bit more about some of the new songs
because I know he said he wanted it to
sound like something you hear on Spotify
as opposed to a Broadway musical yeah
you know and I you know we he and I we
have two daughters and I I really feel
like what I observe about people growing
up in the Spotify generation is that you
take your music from everywhere it's not
like you go to the store you buy the one
album of the person you like so my kids
have very eclectic taste and I thought
like I just want everything to sound
like the way whatever this track is
meant to be and freshes but I think that
probably is where I should probably stop
talking about music because I'm not cool
but like but I won't have the right
language but you know you should answer
more about like how things have changed
and how things sound coming into the
movie yeah I mean I I think that's kind
of that's exactly it like accessibility
to music on one level is like much
different than it used to be um and it's
incredibly it's like right there it's
right there right so I think like you
sort of see like musical theater
specifically becoming something that is
um more like mainstream popular and that
like people really love and consume much
more heavily I think because it's more
accessible mhm
and so it's it's more of like a pop
culture thing now than this thing of
like oh like those like theater kids
it's like no like the theater kids are
actually like the smartest the hottest
the most witty and also the most
aggressive group of people you will ever
meet um and they're all kissing each
other um it doesn't matter um but yeah
so I think like that level of
access makes it so that you love the
song as opposed to the genre like you're
not I don't think you're thinking about
the genre of music as much as you are
the song which I think is just more
music in general um right now like for
instance like I used to hate country
music CU I grew up in like the South and
I was like I don't like the culture
around this where I'm from whatever
whatever now I love country music
because like it's accessible to me in a
way that I can just like go on my phone
and be like Casey Musgraves come on now
in my ears right I think it's the same
sort of thing where like Jeff in the
whole music team have taken like the
Integrity of the songs made it like what
we wanted to make it as of like a couple
months ago and that's where they live
and it's really nice wow God I cannot
wait to hear all the new songs in this
thank you for adding new songs songs and
I think you know I think with the movie
in general we just sort of knew that we
had to find ways for it to be surprising
because the movie the original movie is
always on somewhere right and how can we
sort of surprise and hopefully Delight
people with the music choices with the
actors with you know just the way the
movie shot well Tina if you're involved
it's definitely Delight not hopefully
Delight but and Gary I'm so stoked to
see you in this because this is your
first musical on the big screen I love
seeing you in comedies and thrillers now
you're the lead in this film is Katie um
I was thinking about all the high school
roles that you've done like Spider-Man
and Senior year which you were in
avantica which is about a 14-year-old
Australian immigrant that tries to be
part of the populars and I was thinking
about how you're Australian so I wanted
to ask you what is the funniest thing to
you about the American High School
experience and give you total permission
to roast us oh uh where to begin
um there are so many things that are
very strange to me um so true so true so
many things something I mean the first
high school movie I did I was 16 so I I
well actually no it was Spider-Man so I
was 15 and I didn't know what homecoming
was cuz it was like a the movie was
called Spider-Man
homecoming I don't understand perfect
and they're like oh it's when like I
still don't know what it is the football
team comes home right alumni watch the
football games yeah the football I knew
it was the football thing so um so
there's that and then you know the trays
at the cafeteria like we would just like
bring our lunch to school um the school
the yellow school buses we don't have
that you would walk to school or ride
your bike yeah I know it's crazy very
sick same with like big tall lockers my
school we only got like a third of those
lock like he had a little small one um
the low budget schools still have small
yeah yeah so the red Solo cups at
parties you know we do have those but
only because America has it like we we
only do it because America does it
yeah so
it's sorry it's all those sorts of
things and also something that was very
different is sort of the pressure to go
to college straight after school um a
lot of my friends took Gap years I
didn't go to college so so all those
sorts of different things but the most
exciting thing was just being there and
being part of everything I saw in the
movies because I grew up on movies like
me and girls and I and um High School
Musical and like all these movies that
are about American teens in high school
and so getting to be a part of that was
really exciting cuz I was stepping into
a
movie and it's very different but but
really fun I mean what a roast that was
I love it speaking of roasting let's
move on to someone who play Regina
George who knows a thing or two about
roasting um I'm so excited to talk to
you because you're so Unapologetic and
unfiltered and I really appreciate that
about you Renee and such a rising pop
star and actress I can't wait for people
to see you shine in this especially
because you played Regina George on
Broadway Rachel McAdams has said you're
amazing I was reading an interview you
did where you said you were so happy you
took the original role because it gave
you this like fouryear employment gig oh
yeah which is great yeah no it's my it's
my it's my lifetime job what was it like
getting the call back to come back for
this and what's one lyric that you get
to sing as Regina that's just so
satisfying to you timing is like so
everything and I'm a very uh I I really
like believe in like the universe and
astrology and things like that and it's
very very important to me um and I
didn't grow up like religious or
anything like that so that's something
I've really like latched on to as I've
gotten older um in my sort of like
spiritual like belief system or whatever
you want to call it at the time that I
knew something was going on but I had no
idea that it was about me girls
specifically I was at the same time
going through something
incredibly incredibly difficult uh in in
life maybe like one of the more
traumatic things that has happened to me
uh and it like had a lot to do with like
you know different parts of my life and
different places in some of my jobs and
so I was really really really sad um and
felt like to be quite honest and I was
like on the treadmill which is so funny
just cuz like of course like Regina's
going through things in the movie and
she's like angrily like running and
walking on the treadmill um in the
musical and I was pretty much doing the
same thing I was like trying to like
sweep my anxiety out and uh my mom and
dad like came into my house that I lived
in at the time and we on the phone with
my agents and my manager and like my
best friend knew and they told me and I
like in a very like kitchy like cliche
way like really started crying um
because obviously how cool and I'd known
about it for years and it was a huge
part of my life but I was also really
like I knew that going back in with like
her and Jeff and everybody that I knew
was like involved with the movie I knew
that I would be like really taken care
of and really valued and that meant so
much to me especially at that time I was
like oh wow like The Company You Keep is
so important and I'm so excited to like
be back in those Graces wow yeah it
really felt like you guys were at
Theater Camp was there a song that you
got to sing as Regina that also made you
feel like as powerful and satisfying I
mean well world burn for
sure absolutely yeah I'm like I'm like
uh absolutely I'm like crying and I'm
like oh I'm so happy I'm also like a
so I'm like yeah well was nice to thing
yeah Al you would know a thing or two
about singing satisfying songs see is
that you're Moana and how far I'll go is
like the most gratifying thing to scream
in your car I mean this want a Grammy
for a reason how cool that you're back
playing this Fearless another Fearless
bold character in Janice which is she's
so legendary her song I'd rather be me
is actually the most streamed on Spotify
from the musical um I noticed that
Janice's last name's different online
for this movie I wanted you to tell us
what's different about Janice from the
first time we saw her on the big screen
and what do you love so much about her
spirit yeah that's a great question um
Janice sarkeesian is now Janis IM I am
of native Hawaiian descent so that was
like a really really wonderful Touch of
of you know just incorporating my
culture into this new iteration the
character that I get to play um and I
have been really lucky over the years
that I have been able to choose the
roles that I want and like the ground
rules are very simple like I just want
women that are well written that are
like strong and decide that what they
say is what goes um and I feel like I
really lued out with this character I
also really obviously enjoy singing um I
miss musicals I miss working with like
ensembles you know like like it's so
wonderful to put something together or
to hear like a mix come back and be like
we sound so good learning choreography
together sweating together um like truly
I was running around on the set some of
us had to do live takes like it was a
labor of love and like Blood Sweat and
Tears but I think a lot of times when we
think of stage Productions or movies
it's like ah gosh like what you guys did
like some of that is Magic it's not
magic like none of it is Magic actually
it might feel that way but all of it is
hard work and so to see this come out
like to also come through another
unforeseeable event of a strike like it
feels there's just a gratitude to it
that I think all of us understand yeah
and how sick that you got to do with
green tips singer hair so I love Janet
so much so I can't wait to see you and
the spirit you embody through her um and
her spirit is so well received and
complimented by her best friend Damen
squel so H so Damian the last two years
of your life have been insane I mean you
graduated with a degree in musical
theater in 2021 you were in a strange
loop on Broadway got nominated for a
Tony and now you're in a movie playing a
character that has made so many people
feel seen yeah feels like he's changed
your life a little in a way but I'm not
going to speak for you but I I want to
hear a little bit about that if that's
true for you and also um what was it
like shooting a musical for film as
opposed to doing one on stage yeah well
definitely life-changing for me because
for a long time Damen was the only
plus-sized queer character that boys
like me had um most of the queer men on
you know film or on stage or very buff
or muscular or you know a little
twinkish you know which is nothing wrong
with that but it's also like where do we
belong where do we fit like where's our
place and um that was always Damian for
me so to get to play him especially as a
black man was very special um I think
the question that I always get in my
size and being black is like what sport
do you play and it's like well actually
I sing a little bit and I act a little
bit and I get to twirl for a living you
know so it's it's something really
special and that um other boys get to
see it really excites me um I will say
the difference from a musical on stage
and on film is eight shows a week uh
that's a big difference uh uh and it's
it's very nice to be able to go in the
studio and say this is my best voice
this is me at my strongest at my
healthiest um and that's what people get
to hear you know and it's also nice to
put that acting into the music and into
the character while in the booth and
team music did like such a great job
being like what does Daman sound like
for you and what does this song sound
like through you um and that was really
exciting but just like I think was just
said The Ensemble aspect of it all has
been very beautiful I was in a cast of
seven on Broadway and that was great but
to go in and see all these you know
lovely people and then see the crew and
then see you know background and it's
like we're all working together to
create Northshore to create the high
school experience and it just so happens
to have a little music and a little you
know choreography you know just the the
glitter of theater to it it's been
really exciting you know so I hope that
it translates and people feel the joy
that we felt making it I'm so no no I
only say this just so we all are like
yes like J has like one of the best
voices like he ever so like yeah super
fun to be in an ensemble and also like
so glad you're in the en humble cuz like
we shared a wall in our dressing rooms
and it was the best time of my life I
got to hear that call sing all the time
and I was like holy I was like that's
just
different just different so fun I'm so
inspired hearing you speak about the
character I can't wait to see you shine
in this I mean you're only 25 avantica
you're 18 you're executive producing and
starring in a crown of wishes on Disney
plus which I could ask you a million
questions about but I'll save that for
another day but you are also a talented
dancer trained in ballet classical
contemporary and you play Karen which
means you're in the infamous holiday
talent show and I know that Kyle
hanagami was choreographer on this movie
tell us what it was like working on that
and what can audiences expect from that
scene well I think Kyle is like iconic
for anyone who like grew up being a
dancer and even if you didn't like if
you grew up in like the day and age
where YouTube was just like your
religion every night like he is just
iconic and he is so wonderful in person
this is like my first time back dancing
in a film like since I've done Indian
Cinema and so it was really really nice
to have somebody there who like one knew
what they were doing so well and like
had such a good attention to detail
because I get paranoid and I get scared
that like people aren't being honest
with me and people aren't telling me
what is reading and what's not and he
always did he is just so so talented and
I think people like Tina was saying like
there's so many like hidden Delights in
this movie that make it new and make it
fresh um and hopefully like people see
the dance sequences and are like you
know motivated to get up and dance
themselves because I I really do think
they are so so special the talent show
well I think like it was like our first
dance sequence we did um yeah it was our
first it was week one yeah it was our
first dance sequ yeah isn't that crazy
for
sure it was it was Friday about first
week was when we did it you remember
that no yeah I was there I was there no
I was there I remember every minute yeah
it was crazy and we blocked it like day
of and it was just insane like we really
did this this whole production on such a
tight schedule that everybody was like
like it was great it was like a month
yeah we made the movie in a month yeah
everyone's like everyone was like
confused as to why we were posting like
Mean Girls wrapped like so quickly like
and I was like I promise you we did our
best ever but like like everybody worked
their off and so doing that like being
the first dance that we all did together
I don't know there's something really
bonding about like performing in front
like of like because the audience was
there absolutely like 200
backgrounds there watching and we're
just popping
our and it was I was remember saying to
one you guys it was week one and you had
prepped it so much and rehearsed it so
much and then we shot it and I was like
isn't it you're never going to do that
again yeah you're used to like the stage
like now you'll never ever do well
you'll definitely bust it out at parties
as a party trick
if not going me and my friends still do
it but I just aged myself and that's
embarrassing no
that's on me bie you played Gretchen
Wieners so obviously you were in um that
dance number as well but Ashley Park who
played Gretchen makes a cameo in this
film she played Gretchen in the Musical
on Broadway did you get a chance to talk
to her at all about the character I
didn't that was was like the one day
that I I wasn't there I still haven't
met her which is like a travesty I know
I still haven't met her like we need to
make that
happenly adore her and I wasn't like
super super familiar with the musical I
had you know known of it peripherally
but I hadn't really truly taken a listen
the one song that I knew and had heard
um frequently was what's wrong with me
that was like the one song that I knew I
was like God that's such a pretty song
never did I think I'd be sitting here so
it's very crazy it's crazy I noticed
that you were on 30 Rock over a decade
ago do you remember what your first
impression of Tina Fe was I mean quite
frankly not to be like totes
Amos I think like I probably wouldn't be
a professional actor if I hadn't had
such a positive experience on that day
um I mean Tina was like basically my
first scam partner as a professional
actor um I had been auditioning for a
couple months in New York City and I
booked a part and it was 30 Rock it was
a guest spot and I got to hang out with
Tina and James Marsden all day which was
thrilling for me as a 10-year-old you
know sick I was so excited and it was
really just such a positive experience I
think probably like if I had done that
day and and I was like you know acting
didn't really like it like I probably I
wouldn't be here you know my parents you
know I I'm lucky like my parents didn't
push me this way like I I've always just
wanted to be a performer and they've you
know sort of allowed me um to do that um
and uh I think yeah if I hadn't had such
a positive experience I certainly
wouldn't be doing it now so do I know I
want to say too that you know the I
think phbe was one of the last people
cast in the movie because we had seen a
lot of amazing actresses but gret and
just a really specific specific part to
cast and there was a day when I was like
guys I want to review every single tape
I haven't seen Gretchen yet and I went
and I watched every single Gretchen that
came in and I got to BB and I was like
there there there there she is there she
is and then I looked up her IMDb and I
was like oh my
God I didn't recognize you cuz you're
grown and you were 10 and I was like I
picked BB once and then I saw BB again I
was like and it's BB again and it's just
like stood out to me my heart wow that's
beautiful wow I wanted to ask you about
working with Tina too and hi by the way
you're so good I turned pretty this
summer just cuz I knew I'd be I love you
in that um I was reading
that thanks I worked on that one for a
while I got the Riz as the kids
say o Chris uh I was reading that you
said there was a scene that you were
doing that you weren't sure was Landing
as funny as you wanted it to be and
worked it with Tina and I was hoping you
could share with us what scene that was
and what comedic advice she gave you can
I say what scene it is it was when when
Aaron like sees Regina and and Brian
Shane oh right right when anyways it was
just the the the like eron's reaction to
it and it doesn't have to be a funny
thing but like I it was it's when you're
working on like something that like
moves the way this movie does because it
moves like so quick you're doing so much
of it in little pieces yeah and
sometimes I have trouble with that like
personally like as an actor it's really
hard to like just
like do like do this as opposed to like
you know build up to it or something
like that anyways and so um I just
remember you came out and you just
suggesting things and I was like this
this is funny like hey you're funny yeah
I don't know if you've ever heard that
before but I was like um yeah so that's
sort of that story I don't even know I
don't think it's really a funny moment
even but
um but he's naturally funny he's just
like doesn't understand that doesn't see
it yeah
irregardless no uh that's awesome and
you're so great in so many things but
it's really fun to watch you as the
heart throb and Aaron Samuels is so like
legendary heart throb so excited to see
you in that um before I go Tina you
talked about the power of the burn book
which is obviously so horrible in real
life but so hilarious on the big screen
I thought it'd be fun to end this and
ask you guys what's one thing that would
be in your personal burn book it could
be like a pet peeve like slow Walkers it
could be a thing like high-waisted
shorts um it could be a person that
specif oh like something we'd put in
there just something yeah that would be
on like a page like not about any
speciic it could be anything you want
she she's it open let's not name Nam
like I'm pleading the
fif yeah nice nice burb I guess mine
would be like you're not better than me
cuz you're on a city
bike you're not better than me because
you're on a mechanical City bike like
leave me alone leg like I'll I'll use my
electrical they go fast though they go
are so fun I'm like just because you
want to get like don't judge me for
taking the electric no they're great so
much better sorry the the scooters are
in my B book the electric scooters are
in my electric scooters okay what about
you a month ago um oh I'm already here
somewhere else go first I I don't I
don't left
side um I think I think just need to
learn how to drive
again I just failed my driver's test for
the second time it's really bad that's
good that's that's that's telling us
something their I need people it's too
much so good luck she was like you
shouldn't be on the streets and I was
like I like okay so true
so real like are you fling with me you
pay my
$30 you do it I guess maybe I don't have
a license I just have like a graveyard
of permits that have expired really so
maybe I'm putting like maybe I'm putting
my graveyard of permits in the burm book
and I'm going to learn how to drive you
can
do Past walk
yeah we're all like taking Birds to the
mechanical I want to do that so bad I
want to roll to a premiere on bird or
something what's a I think it's I would
love to oh the the what about you they
are so dangerous they also
burn I don't know I hate when people
chew loud like that makes me want to die
like really it's it's a thing well it's
like actually a thing but it's also like
it's a thing Lise when I hear people
like like d i I get like I see red I
really do yeah no I know you will get
pregnant and die it's it's called
misophonia it is it is called misophonia
you can't stand this it's not even my
fault like I just yeah Fair uh I really
well okay I feel like from I'm just
going through I'm Shuffling my list
right now like she got a scroll uh yeah
for sure uh I would say like I I
actually really really really dislike in
a in a very serious way I don't like
when if you're like in a group with um
people and somebody in that group tries
to like kind of come for somebody else
for no reason I I really really really
dislike that and I'm a very I'm a pretty
Scrappy person and
I am I just cannot do that I don't like
when someone comes for someone else like
for no reason like if you don't have
Merit don't you dare cuz then you're
giving me Merit right so then the table
have turned um but I really don't like
that also I said this earlier but don't
act dumb I just don't like when people
act dumb like if you know what you did
stand
up Rene's a girl girl we don't ever have
to
worry I say for my burn book I think I
might have
to I'm G to have to put people that
still say Beyonce's overrated
[Applause]
and so I say that because I just think
we we have learned look sorry you can
see I'm getting intense I'm I think we
have learned as a collective we've seen
a lot of artists come and go and for
there to be an artist that I can say was
there from my birth until me being in
the Mean Girls movie corre I think it
just shows longevity I don't know I mean
and overrated to who like who are we
comparing her to maybe let's not compare
let's let her be an artist let's let all
artists be artist m that's what I want
to put people who compare artists
because art is subjective and what are
you and can you do what good have we get
a I'm sorry I needed that this morning
now I'm ready for
press very true though we have one left
I don't know how to end that but
speaking of misophonia someone told me I
had misophonia because I can't stand
when people crack their Knuckles around
me like it like do you feel it in your
body my I just hate when people come at
other people you don't like it wait you
don't like
it so funny CU I crack my Knuckles all
the time I'm sorry I won't cuz I'm next
to you I do too you guys are hilarious
thank you so much for letting me sit
with you thank you for writing this
making this thank you for making fetch
happen and thank you guys so much for
watching tickets to the new Mean Girls
movie is on sale right now on pho.com my
name's aspr it's not Wednesday but
obviously I still had to wear pink
[Applause]
so